speaking of uh winning this is music to
my ears daily y reports by the end of
the day Tuesday the plummet and Target's
share prices reached the longest losing
streak the chain has suffered in almost
five years Target share prices have
fallen for eight straight days plunging
another
3.666 percent on Tuesday reaching um 133
dollars as the store has lost a
staggering 12 billion dollars in market
value in the last 14 days
um and this is all in the wake of the
consumer boycott triggered by its lgbtq
merchandise Target CEO Brian Cornell
stated to employees last week quote what
you've seen in recent days went well
beyond discomfort it's been
gut-wrenching to see what you've
confronted in our aisles
um and that was him you know trying to
make themselves the victim of this
uh the victim of their own choices and
their own behavior and their own
decision to push the LGBT stuff and the
trans stuff on kids
and now they are they're suffering the
consequences of this
I mean this is look the the Bud Light
boycott was a really big deal
because it was the first and because it
was a a uh you know because of the
symbolic nature of it
um and that's the argument that as you
know I made all along
it's not just about Bud Light it's the
symbolism here
okay basically we we take Bud Light and
we we put its head on a on a pike
uh okay on the you know at the entrance
of the town to to show the other woke
corporations this is what we can do this
is what this we can actually do this to
you we can we can destroy you
and if you show contempt for us as you
have for so many years and you spit in
our face
and you you try to shove this stuff in
our face and in our kids faces this is
what we'll do to you so that was the
great significance of the target of the
boy uh Bud Light boycott rather
Target boycott
also has incredible symbolic
significance but then but it's on top of
that just the the the fact that a you
know a company like this Bud Light is
one thing it's a big victory
but Bud Light is a product just one
product easily replaced by any uh many
other products that taste just as bad as
it and are just as cheap
um Target different deal though you know
Target is um is a much bigger fish to
fry
and the fact that they've
sustained this kind of damage this
quickly is uh I mean it it
would be hard to overstate the
significance of it
now just like we said with Bud Light it
only really matters if we sustain it
so if conservatives are happy with this
and they say well we got the purely
symbolic Victory and now we'll go back
to shopping a Target again you know if
we do that then it doesn't really mean
anything in fact the symbolism at that
point works against us because then the
world corporations can see that okay
yeah if you do the woke stuff uh you'll
upset them for a few weeks and they'll
be mad about it and you know maybe they
won't shop there for you please but
they'll always come back
that's the message that we would send
did you know our friends at genucel have
upgraded their most popular package to
feature their top selling deep firming
vitamin C serum plus Ultra retinol
moisturizer with natural retinal
alternative you probably didn't know but
now you do because right now you can
take advantage of this limited time
package upgrade for 70 off why waste
time and money to go get work done on
your face when you can get genusal skin
care shipped right to your door gen
yourself secret is a family recipe for
over 20 years that makes it safe for all
skin types and perfect for both men and
women made by a compounding pharmacist
in small batches and is always safe
cruelty free and natural you know my
prompter and clip operator markella has
developed so many wrinkles since she
started working here that she's gone
from looking like she's 20 to 200 in the
matter of weeks she literally looks like
a raisin it is deeply disturbing for
everyone around her to help Connor
counteract the ungodly wrinkles she's
developed she's started using genucel as
you know I require everyone around me to
use genucel when I see see them I just
start throwing genucel products at them
and I say put this on immediately well
she started using it now she she looks
uh maybe 100 years old now instead of
200 so there is Improvement go to
genucel.com walshyt try geniusell's most
popular package for 70 off featuring
both genu sales Ultra retinal and Jenny
cell's Firming Serum get a complimentary
Spa Essentials box with every package
order plus free upgrade to priority
shipping get all of that if you go to
genucel.com Walsh YT that's
geniusell.com
Walsh YT
um
but I feel pretty confident I think it's
different
things are just different now
um and I don't I think there are a lot
of people and I've talked to many uh
many people in this boat just normal
people with families you know moms and
dads talk to many of them and say we're
just done with Target we're not going
back to Target
okay for a lot of families it's like
Target is very much a part of the weekly
routine you end up going to Target once
or twice a week
um but then when you say okay I'm
cutting Target out we're going to figure
out how to live without Target you
discover pretty quickly that okay yeah
it's actually pretty easy to well we
don't need Target we release other
places we can go
and once people figure that out that
they don't really need you
um then you're in trouble
and target has also sustained the kind
of brand damage that Bud Light sustained
now I think for a lot of people they
wouldn't want to be seen walking into a
Target uh you wouldn't want to be seen
carrying Target bags around
I mean to be seen walking out of a
Target carrying the target bag with the
target symbol uh it's like you're a
groomer too
that's the kind of branding it's
embarrassing it's humiliating
and uh I think that kind of branding has
set in and that's a that's a major
problem for Target
hard to recover from that
so things are different now
um and they're different for a lot of
reasons one of them is just sheer
exhaustion
after a while people get fed up
and the LGBT activists they've been
running roughshod over the culture for
years and they've been getting
everything they want
and getting more bold about it and more
outlandish and more egregious
and more grotesque
and they keep pushing it and keep
pushing it and keep pushing it and then
eventually people say even a lot of the
people that went along with it because
they were too afraid or they didn't care
they were like you know they were they
were uh
apathetic about it
many of them are now saying this is too
much I'm I'm sick of it I'm tired of it
I'm exhausted with it just stop leave us
alone
and the thing is once the bat once
people get sick of it
you know they don't really they don't
end up drawing the line at the most
recent most egregious thing that you did
they draw it all the way back at the
beginning
and they say we don't want any of this
just leave us alone get it all out of
here
which is why now there's an attitude by
many people on the right that um yeah we
don't want
uh anything that promotes gender
ideology or transgenderism to kids we
don't want the really super uh extreme
stuff
satanic merchandise because we don't
want that we also you know what we're
saying now we don't even we don't want
Pride flags at all but we don't don't
even we don't even want to see the pride
flag we don't want any of it
that's what many on the right are saying
and I'm glad they are
I mean I that's where I've been all
along but I'm glad that um
this is becoming the mainstream view on
the right
and you know whose fault it is
I mean it's all their fault if you're an
LGBT activist and you're feeling very
persecuted by this and you're saying
what happened now we can't even fly a
pride flag without you well that's your
fault
yeah you couldn't
if you had uh just stopped at like where
you were at say in say the year 2017.
okay if you had stopped there and you
said okay we basically won and you just
stopped
um
then probably none of this would happen
but you kept going and you kept pushing
and now you're reaping the consequences
of that and I'm so glad that you are hey
YouTube thanks for listening to the show
if you'd like access to my full show
with no ads you should go to
dailywire.com and use promo code Walsh
to get two months free on all annual
plans see you there